endlich mal tolle nachrichten die eu hat
sich auf ein sechster sanktionspaket
gegen putin geeinigt inklusive öl
embargo das wird ihm eine lehre sein
oder auch nicht denn möglicherweise
profitiert der verbrecher sogar noch und
kriegt für weniger öl mehr geld zumal
seine pipeline player ja weiter nach
europa fließt und wir ihn bis zum
jahresende zeit geben neue kunden fürs
öl auf dem seeweg zu finden ist jetzt
halt so wir hoffen einfach mal dass die
sanktionen trotzdem wirken und nicht nur
die inflation bei uns beschleunigen kann
ich dazu vielleicht mal aufmunternden
klartext hören und wenn wir das so
machen dann glaube ich haben wir auch
eine chance dass die zukunft als
möglichkeit begriffen wird er auf die
man mit hoffnung setzen kann
ja richtig erkannt scholz zitiert ihn
natürlich den alten kino klassiker
zurück in die zukunft die als
möglichkeit begriffen wird auf die man
mit hoffnung setzen kann
der schlimmste aus der trilogie aber
zurück zum öl-embargo der eu das ist ja
schon ein ganz wichtiges signal an putin
muss man sagen gut so richtig erst ab
jahresende und nur für öl das auf
schiffen kommen in bulgarien bleibt
selbst das erlaubt
weil das land mit b anfängen keine
ahnung ungarn tschechien und die
slowakei kriegen erstmal unbegrenzt
weiter pipeline öl ach ja und
griechenland zypern und malta dürfen
russisches öl auch an putins ersatz
kunden außerhalb der eu verschiffen also
die verdienen dann an der umgehung des
embargos kurze frage warum darf man das
überhaupt noch embargo nennen tja da
fragen sie mich was ja ja ich weiß
wochenlanger streit in der eu und am
ende steht wie immer eigentlich ein
teurer scheinkompromiss alles damit
viktor orban seinen willen kriegt so
schlimm mit den üblichen mafiamethoden
erpresst putins bester mann in brüssel
den rest von europa überlegen sie mal
nicht mal ein krieg schafft es diese eu
wirklich zusammen zu schweißen haben sie
sich mal gefragt warum die doofen
apokalypse film von roland emmerich
immer in den usa spielen und nie bei uns
weil es ein scheiß film wäre ja stellen
sie sich mal vor
feindlicher aliens landen in brüssel und
verlangen den anführer zu sprechen und
dann google terrain und sagt warte mal
die haben gar keinen anführer das sind
27 regierungschefs die aber immer alles
einstimmig entscheiden müssen
gut sagt der chef dann will ich den
mächtigsten von den 27 sprechen und dann
kommt olaf scholz raus und sagt sachen
wie wir werden einen diktator iden der
aliens niemals akzeptieren und
deutschland würde dafür zwar keine
schweren waffen einsetzen um die aliens
nicht unnötig zu provozieren aber man
könne vielleicht im rahmen eines
ringtausch mit polen aber immer im
einvernehmen mit unseren partnern und
nach ungefähr zehn minuten von dem
gelaber
können wir jetzt nicht mehr ende
jetzt hin
deswegen immer usa in europa ja ich
hab's ja gesagt ist ein scheiß schön
währenddessen verwandelt sich wladimir
putin immer mehr in einen lupenreinen
bond bösewicht es wird immer
schrecklicher der mann droht jetzt offen
mit einer weltweiten hunger und
flüchtlingskrise es sei denn man lässt
die sanktionen fallen absolut skrupellos
und dieser putin treue duma-abgeordnete
hier hat seinen ganz eigenen teuflischen
plan da kommt der tag irgendwann in
naher zukunft wird irgendein
nato-verteidigungsminister mit dem zug
nach kiel fahren die insel lenski zu
besuchen aber er wird dort nie ankommen
und irgendwo in moskau aufwachen
und jeder kunde der deutschen bahn kennt
das
du hast ein ticket nach gütersloh
gekauft aber wegen geänderter wagen rast
in moskau auf das ist da sind uns doch
alle schon passiert frage wie viel
bringt es eigentlich noch mit ihm hier
zu reden olaf scholz als ich gerade
wieder ein 80 minuten telefonat mit
putin angetan
ja
ja in einer dreier konferenz mit
präsident marco mann soll den
gesprächsfaden nicht abreißen lassen
andererseits kommen von putin eh nur
lügen und die premierministerin von
estland fragt zu recht wenn man jemanden
isolieren will warum ruft man ihnen
ständig an vor allem aber was bitte
redet man 80 minuten am stück mit putin
ganz ihnen sagen am anfang fragt marco
so herr putin wann ziehen sie sich
zurück aus der ukraine und der antwortet
sie haben mich zum lachen gebracht gott
segne sie
ja und dann nimmt er parallel ein anruf
von gerd schröder an und lässt scholz
und macao die restlichen 79 minuten in
der warteschleife
so kommen sie auf
ja
putin ist sowas wie die ultimative
herausforderung und unsere antwort wird
leider nicht immer sehr durchdacht
einerseits öl-embargo also in der
theorie das unterbinden des handels mit
russischen öl
gleichzeitig steigern wir die nachfrage
mit dem tank rabatt das ist extrem
widersprüchlich um nicht zu sagen fast
schon pathologisch was wir da machen
wirklich jetzt
außerdem warum mineralölkonzerne mit so
einem tank rabatt noch reicher machen
denn selbst wenn die konzerne denen
rabatt eins zu eins an den kunden
weitergeben was sie nicht machen werden
gibt es immer noch fetten zusatzgewinn
für die weil natürlich mehr leute tanken
werden in den nächsten monaten der tank
rabatt das medienevent der woche eine
sinnlose live schalte nach der anderen
man muss wirklich sagen hier in dieser
tankstelle in münchen ist es ziemlich
ruhig wir morgen wir stehen ja noch
freien tankstelle in berlin friedrich
sein das ist relativ leer an dieser
tankstelle beispielsweise ist gerade
aktuell ein auto vorgefahren guck mal
tatsächlich ist hier momentan noch gar
nichts los ja ist angenehm ruhig man
sieht jetzt im hintergrund die preise
sind jetzt gerade ein bisschen gesunken
also wenn jetzt können wir einmal kurz
hier auf die tafel zeigen gerade haben
wir ein auto jetzt kommt das nächste das
sieht aber so aus als würde der sich
beispielsweise nur einen kaffee holen
eilmeldung es war ein cappuccino mit
hafer milch
breaking news die preise für rohöl und
für benzin haben sich übrigens schon vor
wochen in deutschland entkoppelt und die
spritpreise sind in den tagen vor dem
tank rabatt auffällig hoch gegangen
verdächtig hochgegangen wollten die
mineralölkonzerne möglicherweise vom
steuer rabatt profitieren bevor er kommt
wir schalten wir live an eine tankstelle
in berlin zu holger stockhaus von
bp/aral er stocker aussagen ihr da
gerade ordentlich ab nein das weise ich
entschieden zurück wir sind eine seriöse
branche darf ich vorstellen die jungs
von esso total und shell groß wir feiern
heute die ersten drei tagen tank rabatt
etwas geht
alle tierisch gut drauf wir haben unsere
gewinne im ersten quartal im vergleich
zum vorjahr auf 34 milliarden dollar
verdoppelt und da kribbelt uns der
lindner jetzt noch im tank rabatt
obendrauf geilomat so leute glas e10 auf
ex der nicht mitbringt ist ein grüner
ja also ich will ja nichts unterstellen
er stockers aber die jüngere deutsche
geschichte lehrt dass solche
steuersenkungen selten komplett beim
kunden landen wir hatten ja kürzlich die
mehrwertsteuersenkung für sechs monate
in der krise und da haben wir gesehen
dass etwa ein drittel in die kassen der
anbieter geflossen ist also in die
kassen der mineralölkonzerne
ja und das heißt auch nicht dass wir das
beim tank rabatt genauso machen
vielleicht erreichen wir ja diesmal noch
viel mehr
da guckst du blöd der fette welke das
ist alles legal freundin das problem es
gibt keine gesetzliche verpflichtung die
steuersenkung an den kunden
weiterzugeben unsere befürchtungen sind
dass die mineralölkonzerne das durchaus
nutzen um da den ein oder anderen cent
als mitnahme mitzunehmen
was hat er denn ein cent sind wir
überhaupt nicht interessiert
feiert mal schön bis das kartellamt
eingreift die haben schon ein
verschärftes monitoring- angekündigt das
kartellamt beobachtet uns ja scheiß die
wand ein was machen wir denn jetzt ach
guck mal da vorne sitzt schon wieder so
einer und beobachtet unsere preise
wie läuft das monitoring immer alles
schön aufschreiben vollidiot herr welke
es ist so toll in deutschland zu
arbeiten in england griechenland und
italien gibt es bald mit über
gewinnsteuern das heißt unternehmen die
vom krieg profitieren müssen davon was
abgeben geht's noch ist schon wie der
ddr oder was es wird bei uns nie kommen
in diesem sinne auf die rheinländer
ganz toll 3 milliarden steuer krümmel
für drei monate fucking tank rabatt da
kann man wirklich nur hoffen dass
möglichst viele leute doch ihr auto
stehen lassen und auf e bike umsteigen
gerade mal ein gutes stichwort da kommt
ja schon wieder direkt zum opfer hinein
wo willst du hin hast du dich verfahren
das hier ist unsere holt halten fest
money ich verstehe die reifen hier
holger stockhaus vielen dank
und herren
dafür gibt es aber eine erfreuliche
wende in sachen zeitenwende die zeiten
wenden sich jetzt wohl doch wer hätte es
gedacht und zwar für unsere bundeswehr
100 milliarden sondervermögen kommen
heute im bundestag beschlossen die
truppe ist also ab sofort steinreich
also sie kann den soldatinnen und
soldaten erstmals vernünftige stiefel
kaufen was zwar am beschaffungs elend
bei den großgeräten erstmal nichts
ändert aber 100 frische milliarden zum
verband für unsere eigene armee kommen
also demnächst moderne waffen die
ukraine kriegt das wissen sie vor allem
antiquitäten zb den gepard hier olaf
scholz als gebrauchtwagenhändler und es
kommt diese waffe mit einer
erstausstattung von 59.000 schuss
munition und das reicht für 1200
bekämpfung vorgänger
bekämpfung vorgänger link direkt viel
harmloser oder wollt ihr den totalen
bekämpfung vorgang 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr reden wir darüber mit dem
einzigen garantiert ungebeten
sicherheitsexperten den das deutsche
fernsehen zu bieten hat mit olaf
schubert olaf schön dass du da bist ja
die bundeswehr könnte schon wissen wir
seit heute in wenigen jahren in der lage
sein das land im ernstfall regelrecht zu
verteidigen was macht das mit ihren
also das würde mich schon entlassen ja
also momentan verteidige ich deutschland
ja im prinzip alleine mit einer der
schärfsten waffen die es gibt mit meinem
verstand
sicherlich auch noch paar flachs raketen
zwischendurch aber spaß beiseite ich
denke die bundeswehr könnte schon viel
eher wehrhaft sein denn ich meine viele
ja eher so auch rechtsorientierte
soldaten haben ja viele waffen und viel
munition mit nach hause genommen hier
hat man könnte ja mal fragen ob sie
vielleicht bereit wären einen bruchteil
wieder abzugeben mich fragen ist ja
jetzt eine sondersituation
aber dann merkt man das ist eben die
bundeswehr sie so ein bisschen so ein
verkoster verein das habe ich bei meiner
musterung selber auch schon gemerkt ja
ich habe gesagt okay ich würde sofort
bei der bundes mehr anfangen als general
und er hat dieses eben gleich nein das
geht nicht man müsste da alle gerade
irgendwie hierarchisch durchlaufen was
ja völlig das ist ja dann meine oma
schon gesagt also wenn du jockey werden
willst musst du vorher nicht fährt
gewesen sein
also eine kluge frau
trotz trotz 50 milliarden wer etwa im
jahr hat es bislang nicht mal für warme
unterwäsche oder stiefel für die
soldaten gereicht was läuft da falsch
beim management und beschaffung also was
heißt nur ist falsch was willst du mit
stiefeln und unterwäsche ja ich meine
damit kannst du den feind jetzt wirklich
nicht vertreten also ist es sei denn ist
es ganz lange getragene unterwäsche ja
also das ist wieder so etwas deutsches
ja warme wäsche ich meine weise jedoch
arbeit ist die wärmste jacke
ich meine aber mal so gesagt 50
milliarden klar das klingt immer
irgendwie viel aber das ist dann auch
schnell alle ich merke das auch privat
deutsche waffen sind nun mal immer
besonders teuer da gibt es so viel zu
beachten durch die
arbeitsstättenverordnung also zum
beispiel die deutschen panzer sie hat
ihr haben immer extra großer
einstiegsluke damit auch schwangere
soldaten und soldatinnen bequem
zusteigen können ja und dann irgendwie
dort wo die granaten lagen dann kommt an
maxi cosi hinten ist noch ein aufkleber
drauf marvin an bord dann gehen
irgendwann natürlich die kosten durch
die decke und deshalb denke ich
bräuchten wir eher intelligente waffen
ja das ist die zukunft intelligente
waffen ist so etwas wie der
tarnkappenbomber
das ist spitze intelligenten den siehst
nicht ja und da kannst du den feind
angst machen da kannst du sagen wir
haben davon 10.000 stück
jetzt wissen weiterzugeben auch in der
deutschen bevölkerung war ja so die
grundeinstellung bei vielen zumindest ja
wir haben zwar eine bundeswehr weil die
partner das erwarten aber brauchen die
wirklich seine armee war das im
nachhinein sauber war pazifismus oder
doch eher blödheit
also ich denke ich rede im namen aller
friedliebenden vernünftigen menschen
wenn ich sage die welt wird nicht
sichere durch waffen sondern die welt
wird nur sichere durch ganz ganz viele
waren ja und der pazifismus ich sagen
wie soll ich sagen er hat das heißt also
wenn wir jetzt eine auf die rechte wange
geschlagen will dann halte ich ihm meine
kinder hin oder
also da ist und der patient muss ist per
se gut aber er muss ich natürlich auch
entwickeln und mit der zeit gehen er
muss sich anpassen an die situation also
ich denke der pazifismus ist nicht mehr
ganz gewaltfrei in zukunft sondern er da
darf man auch mal schubsen oder mit dem
spitzen stopp gebiet ja also das ist
irgendwie sowas wie die freundschaft
plus
plus andersrum also ich meine endeffekt
so etwas wie gewalt in der ehe das ist
nicht schön aber gehört dazu
bin sehr froh dass ich deine zuschauer
passten nicht beantworten muss olaf
schubert meine damen und herren
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist mine der stelle
[Musik]